c'était donc endoctrinement un
documentaire auquel vous pouvez réagir
sur le hashtag docu débat un
documentaire que vous avez réalisé
stéphane horel merci d'être avec nous
avec mais également à vos côtés
dominique gombert un bonjour vous êtes
directeur de l'évaluation des risques à
l'agencé nationale de sécurité sanitaire
de l'alimentation de l'environnement et
du travail
michèle rivasi juste en face de vous
députée européenne française euros
europe ecologie les verts membres du
groupe de travail sur la stratégie
française pour les perturbateurs
endocriniens
merci d'être là et enfin patrick levy
bienvenus vous êtes médecin conseil
auprès de l'union des industries
chimiques alors l'abord stéphane horel
ce documentaire c'est le deuxième que
vous réalisez sur ce sujet vous avez
même écrit un livre sur le même thème
d'où vous vient cet intérêt pour les
perturbateurs endocriniens avant
l'intérêt vient du fait que quand j'ai
commencé à m'intéresser à la question
des polluants chimiques
en 2006 je me suis aperçu que cette
question des perturbateurs endocriniens
qui était discuté dans le milieu
scientifique depuis le début des années
90 était totalement absente du débat
public des médias dans les archives du
monde à l'époque avait une seule
occurrence du terme perturbateurs
endocriniens alors que de toute évidence
il y avait là un problème de santé
publique majeur qu'est ce que vous avez
voulu montrer ici précisément le
lobbying d'abord parce que j'ai voulu
montrer c'est comme en s'intéressant à
des questions de santé publique et
d'environnement
on peut montrer comment la démocratie
européenne dysfonctionne profondément
serre qui est une liane une recherche
scientifique est menée sur sur un
problème de santé publique
ces données scientifiques ne sont ne
sont pas utilisés par des par une
administration qui est censé protéger la
population européenne sous l' influence
de l'industrie mais aussi par parce
qu'il ya un état d'esprit à la
commission européenne européenne qui est
ultra libérale est qui et qui fait que
bizarrement la santé des gens est moins
importante que préserver des emplois
ça a été compliqué de le monter
documentaire ça vous appelez combien de
temps j'ai travaillé deux ans dessus sur
en termes d' enquête
donc c'est très long c'est très long à
faire et ce qui la principale difficulté
que j'ai rencontrés c'est quelque part
c'est même pas l'industrie parce que
l'industrie
je les remercie d'ailleurs n'a pas
accueilli au lance flammes j'ai pu
discuter avec eux ils ont accepté de
témoigner dans le film c'est la
commission européenne qui n'aime pas
qu'on dérange le petit confort d'un sens
opposé de son opacité et j'ai eu des
fins de recevoir pour certains
entretiens à la commission européenne et
j'ai été extrêmement choqué par
l'arrogance en fait de cette de cette
administration
alors on voit la direction générale
santé consommateurs la direction
générale entreprises et la direction
générale environnement ne sont pas
d'accord en gros la commission
européenne ne parle pas d'une seule voix
c'est c'est comme un gouvernement et on
n'a pas les mains de sensibilité sur des
thèmes selon si on travaille au
ministère de la santé ou à bercy
c'est la même chose à bruxelles le
problème c'est que la dg environnement à
bruxelles c'est un peu le village
gaulois d'astérix et obélix
ils sont ils sont un peu les seuls
porteurs de cette cet idéal européen de
préserver leur environnement du principe
de précaution qui est inscrit dans les
textes européens et autour d'eux et ils
ont des directions générales qui n'ont
qui n'ont en tête que de préserver la
compétitivité des entreprises comme si
c'était forcément contradictoire vos
réactions à ce documentaire michèle
rivasi moi je tiens à féliciter mais
l'amour elle d'avoir fait ce
documentaire est d'ailleurs gelé
présenté le 4 janvier au parlement et il
y avait des gens de la commission qui
étaient là pour d'abord écouter un peu
ce qu'on disait en fait il ya vrai
rapport de force à l'heure actuelle il
faut voir que la commission ne joue pas
le pourquoi de son existence puisque il
ya eu un rapport de parlementaires
notamment de l'amour et selon qu'ils
étaient une députée européenne suédoise
casseurs à pau où tous les
parlementaires
on était d'accord avec ces conclusions
des critères etc
et puis il ya une deuxième chose c'est
que il y avait des deux directives une
directive sur les biocides ouailles et
c'est tout ce qu'on utilisera la maison
ancien des produits chimiques
et puis une directive sur les pesticides
et il était mentionné que la commission
devait apporter des critères pour
définir ce qu'est un perturbateur
endocrinien d'ici 2013 près or les armes
de vie voilà décembre 2013 décembre 2013
rien et puis le conflit entre la dg
environnement la dg entreprises et puis
la dg sanco aussi sainte et les
consommateurs donc là dessus nous les
parlementaires on est remonté au créneau
en disant mais c'est inadmissible
puisque normalement si c'est un
perturbateur endocrinien on doit pas le
retrouver dans les biocides qu'on
utilise tous et aussi au niveau des
pesticides et c'est là où ils nous font
une entourloupe en nous disant alors
avec quand même manger à apporter les
lettres ils ont reçu des mails ont reçu
des mails de bailleurs en disant non non
non non il faut surtout pas avoir ces
critères il faut absolument qu'on fasse
d'abord une étude d'impact économique
voilà ce qui veut dire j'explique les
spectateurs c'était une étude pour
savoir en gros évalué le manque à gagner
de l'industrie si demain on devait
réglementé drastiquement tous les
amateurs et là dessus donc ça ça a pris
du temps et maintenant il ya une
ministre suédoise de ministres de
l'environnement qui a attaqué la
commission pour carences et donc la
saisie la cour de justice européenne
moi j'ai fait un lobbying incroyable au
niveau des parlementaires et monsieur
schulz qui est président du parlement
européen a attaqué également
et maintenant les 28 rames en attaque la
commission donc vraiment il ya un
problème énorme au niveau de cette
commission qui doit être l'outil
technique
voyez pour proposer des directives or à
l'heure actuelle comme ça a été dit elle
joue pas à son rôle technique
elle joue un rôle politique l'avancé son
indépendance en fait qui est qui remise
en cause là alors les par les états
membres
c'est son indépendance c'est le fait
qu'il ya des traités qui définissent
bien quel est le rôle de chacun et que
la commission n'a jamais été élu donc
son rôle si vous laissez de préparer et
de proposer des projets de directives or
là elle devait définir les critères elle
ne le fait pas et vous savez j'ai dit
souvent moi c'est les 3 d alors les
industriels d
ils ont mis les perturbateurs de clients
sur le marché après le deuxième d et
désinforme et 10 non non il n'y a aucun
problème sanitaire
circulez ya rien à voir à navan et puis
il commence à y avoir des lanceurs
d'alerté là c'était les scientifiques
quand commencer à dire attention les
perturbateurs endocriniens sont en train
de développer tous ces cancers
hormono-dépendants l'explosion de cancer
car on a d'ailleurs beaucoup en france
par rapport aux autres pays européens
des malformations l'obésité et c'est ce
qui explique mais je voudrais pas les
emmener mon troisième est quand même
donc ouais il désinforme et le 3e décès
il dit faire alors ils disent amis faut
faire des études supplémentaires on n'a
pas assez d'éléments est comme ça il
gagne du temps et c'est des milliards
que l'industrie 100,1 en poche si vous
voulez parce que il n'ya pas de critères
donc tous ces produits sont dans le
domaine public
et puis vous avez une explosion de
maladies et des maladies chroniques de
plus en plus un montant qui pourrait
pousser à terme et on y reviendra dans
le débat ce qui pourrait pousser les
états à réglementer aux plus anciens
comme la france l'a fait par exemple sur
sur le bisphénol skies et oui la france
là je dois avouer qu'elle a été très en
verve liste d'heureux paix mais ça peut
mais ça peut arriver que les états se
désolidarise ne oui mais vous verrez que
si la france me paraissait tout seul
parce que la wii alors on verra
peut-être plus tard mais là il est dans
une situation difficile
si elle n'a pas l'âge ans il est isolé
qui qui la supportent commun et
légèrement glay patrick les choses
d'abord vous dire que l'industrie
chimique se sent totalement concerné par
ce sujet et qu'elle participe à tous les
niveaux à la construction de la
connaissance scientifique
elle génère des connaissances et par la
construction de l'édifice réglementaire
je crois que le reportage révèle la
complexité du sujet complexité
scientifique avec l'absence de consensus
international et européen sur un certain
nombre de sujets pour parlera du
bisphénol-a tout à l'heure la difficulté
également à construire une
réglementation qui soit une
réglementation proportionnée par rapport
à un sujet d'une grande complexité
ce qui nous renvoie effectivement la
problématique de la définition crois
qu'aujourd'hui il faut être clair
l'industrie souhaite une définition
européenne transversale on va il est
urgent effectivement agir nous
partageons ce constat une pas question
de différer n'avons pas ce langage
aujourd'hui très mauvais goût amer
chérèque nous en tant que agence de
sécurité sanitaire on a un regard
d'observateurs sur ce qui se passe à
bruxelles sur l'élaboration de la
réglementation
moi je voudrais juste quand même
préciser que la question des
perturbateurs endocriniens c'est une
question majeure pour toutes les agences
de sécurité sanitaire c'est pas une
question nouvelle et il ya urgence dans
la mesure où c'est tout ce qu'il ya 25
ans déjà il ya une conférence winfried
avec une déclaration où il y avait des
scientifiques qui globalement et
j'invite chacun relire la déclaration il
ya 25 ans nous expliquer globalement
tout ce à quoi on est encore confronté
aujourd'hui avec énormément de
clairvoyance qui voyait des signaux sur
les écosystèmes parce que la
problématique des perturbateurs
endocriniens concerne à d'abord été
observée dans les écosystèmes dans
l'environnement sur les animaux on
voyait des modifications de fertilité de
comportement donc tout était déjà très
très bien décrit il ya 25 ans
parallèlement à ça on voit alors
effectivement ça a déjà été dit en tant
qu'observateur sanitaire une explosion
de pathologies qu'on peut imaginer quand
même comme étant fortement associée à
des pertes des problématiques de
perturbateurs endocriniens concert
cancers hormono-dépendants troubles du
comportement fertilité reproduction avec
des chiffres qui sont vraiment
réellement interpellant aujourd'hui
et force est de constater que 25 ans
après même si effectivement dans les
textes depuis cinq à six ans on s'est
dit il faut travailler sur les
perturbateurs endocriniens la mécanique
réglementaire n'est pas prête et là
effectivement il ya une forme d'urgence
ce qui veut dire qu'aujourd'hui on est
amené à travailler substance par
substrat gens dehors de toute
réglementation construite et
effectivement ça se fait dans un cadre
qui n'est pas construit et qui pousse à
la polémique avant de revenir plus en
détail sur tous ces points il apparaît
clairement dans le documentaire et c'est
ce que vous venez de dire patrick levy
que la définition même des perturbateurs
endocriniens
c'est le premier
du problème on réécoute un extrait du
documentaire when we make printemps nous
aurons établi des critères pour
identifier les perturbateurs
endocriniens thuriau seront les premiers
au monde en avoir un certain nombre d'
avantages pour les entreprises mais
aussi potentiellement un certain nombre
de coups a potential france le dossier
de la perturbation endocrinienne est un
dossier qui concerne l'ensemble des
secteurs d'activité et si on prend la
chimie donc le secteur de la chimie
général les cosmétiques l'industrie
pharmaceutique les produits de
protection des plantes donc les les
pesticides les biocides que l'on utilise
donc à la maison pour les moufles et
cafards les moustiques sont donc tous
concernés à des degrés variables
d'ailleurs par cette fameuse
perturbation endocrinienne industria
open prime
l'industrie est sur le pied de guerre
tous mais les mobiliser pour faire en
sorte que la définition des
perturbateurs endocriniens soit aussi
limité que possible c'est que les baies
cause essentiellement parce qu'elle veut
continuer à mettre ces produits sur le
marché sans aucune interférence du
régulateur
patrick ali c'est si compliqué que ça de
définir les perturbateurs endocriniens
oui en effet aujourd'hui il ya consensus
sur la définition de l'om est ce alors
que la définit vous permettez je la
livre les acteurs ce sont des substances
chimiques d'origine naturelle ou
artificielle étrangères à l'organisme
qui peuvent interférer avec le
fonctionnement du système endocrinien et
induire ainsi des effets délétères sur
cet organisme ou ses descendants ça ça
ne vous convient pas ça nous convient
pour faire non parfaitement
mais c'est une définition qui n'a pas
été élaboré pour être versée dans un
contexte réglementaire et qui n'est pas
suffisamment opérationnel pour agir dans
les contextes de riches des règlements
biocides phytopharmaceutiques et autres
donc pour nous elle est trop large
il faut y adjoindre des critères
permettant d'identifier des
perturbateurs endocriniens avery ceux
sur lesquels le poids réglementaire
jusqu'à l'interdiction doit s'appliquer
alors on va revenir sur les critères
après dominique gombert vous la
définition pour vous d'intervalle en
ukrainien
effectivement il ya une définition sur
laquelle aujourd'hui à peu près tout le
monde converge mais qui est une
définition très philosophique
en gros c'est quoi la perturbation
endocrinienne donc vous venez de la cité
derrière il faut maintenant un outil
extrêmement pratique les substances
chimiques potentiellement concerner des
centaines intérieur est à peu près cent
vingt-quatre mais beaucoup plus beaucoup
plus aux contributions plus poster je
ressentais au moins j'aurai me dit voilà
on est plusieurs centres voilà plusieurs
centaines donc aujourd'hui il faut être
capable de se dire substance par
substance est ce que finalement cette
substance est susceptible de conduire à
des effets tels que décrits dans la
définition sur laquelle tout le monde
converge dans le cas de l'homme et donc
il faut des critères techniques précis
quel test je prends ma substance comment
je la teste et à partir de ça comme
enjeu la classe est-ce que c'est sûr
est-ce que c'est pas complètement sûr
est-ce que non et ensuite derrière je
déroule la réglementation je la supprime
du marché pour tel ou tel type d' usage
et donc c'est sur ces critères et ces
essais qui seront ensuite réalisés par
l'ensemble des industriels et qui
conduiront à la suppression de telle ou
telle substance pour tel ou tel usage
sur lesquels aujourd'hui effectivement
des débats extrêmement important entre
les différentes forces en présence alors
effectivement on voit que les critères
pose problème et dans votre documentaire
stéphane on voit que la puissance assez
ce qui est privilégié par l'industrie
mais pas du tout par les ong les ong ou
la science et l'industrie a fait du
lobbying l'industrie en particulier
d'une industrie des pesticides mais
l'industrie chimique
et d'inviter les sites de marcher main
dans la main dans cette dans cette
opération de lobbying pour imposer donc
c'est dans cette liste de critères qui
sont hors qui en fait une sorte de deux
grilles de lecture d'interprétation des
tests contre on pourra tester les
perturbateurs endocriniens
on est censé par une liste de critères
qui sont complémentaires les uns des
autres et l'industrie veut introduire un
filtre à l'entrée qui dirait que seuls
les perturbateurs endocriniens aux
effets les plus puissants pour être
considéré comme un perturbateur
endocrinien
c'est considéré par les scientifiques
qui travaillent sur cette question qui
sont des spécialistes incontestés comme
une une condition à eux qui complètement
qui n'a aucune justification
scientifique ça que c'est une astuce de
lobbying actionnaires que ce néo basque
ce n'est absolument pas base espère que
la puissance en fait c'est pas parce que
la substance est la plus puissante
qu'elle est forcément la plus dangereuse
puisque d'autres peuvent être moins
puissantes mais c'est leur présence dans
sur un tir un éventail plus large
dominique aubert michèle rivasi oui
c'est vrai que ça a été une notion qui
est apparue après coup parce que quand
on regarde les perturbateurs
endocriniens ils ont quand même apporter
un changement on appelle ça de paradigme
c'est à dire qu'on s'est aperçu qu'un
très très faible dose et suivant quand
est ce qu'on les prend c'est pour ça que
les femmes enceintes
voyez les foetus était sont vraiment une
cible par rapport à ces perturbateurs et
on s'est aperçu que à très faible dose
ça peut avoir des effets différents aka
plus forte dose et en plus on s'est
aperçu que à très bas niveau il peut y
avoir aussi un effet cocktail
donc en fait l'étude des perturbateurs
voyez à un peu renversé
l'idée que c'est la dose qui fait
l'effet ouv c'est la dose qui fait le
poison et ça c'est très nouveau et ça a
été apportée par toute une série de
scientifiques dont caron après
l'industrie
comment elle pouvait s'en sortir eh bien
elle s'est dit on va être dur seuil
c'est à dire tout ce qui est en dessous
du seuil
on peut y aller et tout ce qui est au
dessus voyez cette notion de potenza de
puissance etc
et là c'est anti c'est pas du tout
scientifique et donc là en ce moment il
ya vraiment un combat entre la demande
qu'ont fait les parlementaires que font
les états en disant on veut vraiment une
définition
transversale et bien sûr définition
scientifique
maintenant avec cette étude d'impact a
été demandé par la commission
on voit que comment on va allier si vous
voulez le profit des industries
chimiques par rapport à la santé
or c'est des milliards que on dépense à
cause de toutes les maladies qu'on a et
le déficit de la sécurité sociale voyez
c'est nous qui allons le payer parce
qu'on va nous imposer des molécules qui
devrait être complètement exclu
quels critères selon vous devrait être
retenu de mes gonds vert ou est ce que
c'est une question de critères déjà je
pense qu'il faut se poser la question de
savoir pourquoi on évoque de nouveau
type de critère pour les perturbateurs
endocriniens
alors que pour un grand nombre d'autres
molécules qui font aujourd'hui l'objet
définition de classification qui sont
les substances cancérogènes mutagènes ou
reprotoxiques on a déjà une mécanique
qui est extrêmement bien rodée et là
effectivement pourquoi finalement ne pas
appliquer le même type d' approche que
pour l'ensemble de ces substances
sachant que vraisemblablement elles sont
d'une complexité et d'une subtilité des
faits encore plus grande
bon on peut se poser la question donc
moi je pense qu'on a aujourd'hui des
mécaniques de classification qui sont
extrêmement puissante sur par exemple
les substances cancérogènes
évidemment c'est pas exactement le même
type de tests qu'il faut décliner
derrière philosophiquement on est dans
une mécanique qui doit être extrêmement
proches patrick levy vous ces critères
en fait vous soutenez donc je rappelle
que vous êtes conseil auprès des
industriels
vous soutenez ce critère de puissance ou
est-ce que vous êtes ouvert avec
l'industrie à une autre évaluation des
critères faut bien comprendre qu'on
cherche à faire entrer les substances
dans un cadre réglementaire et la
priorité des priorités c'est
identification des substances qui
peuvent être qualifiés de perturbateurs
endocriniens avérée
si on raisonne sur la définition de ms
on a effectivement c'est évoquer la
possibilité d'entraîner des centaines
voire des milliers de substances et
définition car elle ne permet pas de
différencier les substances avérée des
substances qui ont intéressé celles sur
lesquelles on aurait des certitudes
c'est pour lequel il ya une forte
présomption ou une forte probabilité
qu'elle entraîne des effets sur la santé
humaine et sur lesquels on doit très
certainement aller vers des mécanismes
de restriction voire d'interdiction par
exemple ou tout à fait convaincu par
exemple
quand ils canton en 2011 l'union
européenne a décidé d'interdire le
bisphénol a dans les biberons
vous vous en avez pensé quoi on n'est
plus dans l'application du principe de
précaution par rapport à des populations
vulnérables mais nous avons soutenu 7,7
cette position à ce stade
aller au delà
le commissaire européen john dalli avait
déclaré c'est une bonne nouvelle pour
les consommateurs et pour les parents
européens
donc quand même il ya une vraie démarche
dans ce cadre là le fait effectivement
s'intéresser en priorité aux populations
vulnérables
lorsqu'il ya une incertitude sur
l'évaluation sont sept scientifiques ça
nous semble ça nous semble acceptable
dans ce cas là nous ne pouvons pas dire
le contraire je reviens aux critères
puissance pour bien faire la part des
choses entre des substances à fort
potentiel de perturbation endocrinienne
celles qui ne font qu à lui mais des
signaux qui ne sont pas réellement des
perturbateurs mais qui ont une activité
endocrines et bien le critère le plus
important pour nous c'est en effet la
puissance
c'est un critère qui existe déjà dans
notre classement par exemple les
sensibilisant respiratoire dans le
classement clp le règlement européen qui
vise la classification des substances
prend en compte la puissance
pourquoi ne pas le faire pour les
perturbateurs endocriniens implicitement
pour les cancérogènes mutagènes et
toxiques pour la reproduction
implicitement vous prenez en compte la
substance dans la catégorisation mais
pas la peau non non vous connais pas la
licence sur les cancérigènes toxiques et
les mutagènes n'y a pas ce constat garde
il est tout nouveau si on est
cancérigène l'on n'est pas cancérigène
on n'est pas plus ou moins un peu
bourgeois et passionnément ou est la
folie c'est la même chose pour les
perturbateurs endocriniens il ya des
lacs sur la sachant qu pour être très
très clair sur la mécanique de
classification qui est assez robuste
établi dans le cadre du cirque de l' oms
notamment du règlement clp
on va de on ne s'est pas avéré en
accumulant des niveaux de preuve c'est à
dire sur le fait qu'on comprend le
mécanisme d'action 1 in vivo et in vitro
qu'ensuite on a des preuves
épidémiologiques c'est à dire oui j'ai
des populations qui ont été exposés et
oui je vois émerger tel type de
pathologie et quand on a effectivement
tous les niveaux de preuve on devient
avérait et donc je ne vois absolument
pas pourquoi cette mécanique de niveau
de preuve avec la toxicologie et
l'épidémiologie ne fonctionnerait pas
pour les perturbateurs endocriniens
alors restons à l'exemple du bisphénol a
j'explique aux téléspectateurs le
bisphénol a en fait à une structure
moléculaire proche de celle des hormones
ce qui veut dire qu'il peut modifier le
système hormonal
et donc il y a eu suite à cette
interdiction ça veut dire qu'il ya un
consensus sur ces effets c'est à dire
sur la femme enceinte et l'enfant à
naître à savoir le risque que l'enfant
développe un cancer du sein plus tard
donc ça il ya eu consensus sur sur ses
effets la wii alors d'abord la france a
été pionnière il ya eu une loi c est le
pays au monde à d'ailleurs à avoir tout
inventé
on a réussi à le faire accepter au
niveau de l'europe alors ça a été aussi
l'eau de votre agence parce qu'il y
avait suffisamment preuves pour montrer
qu' il fallait l'interdire et l'europe a
suivi et donc il ya eu interdiction de
vol sur les l'histoire des biberons mais
c'est après parce que dans la loi
française il était dit qu'en 2015
il fallait éliminer le bisphénol dans
tout ce qu'on appelle les contenants
alimentaires aussi bien aussi la
vaisselle avec league et qui contient
aussi de bisphénol est là blocage
1 parce que nous on a fait son plan
français mais sur le plan européen
l'agencé européenne sur ces produits de
santé et alimentaire a dit non on n'a
pas suffisamment preuve et c'est là où
on se rend compte d'ailleurs c'est
aberrant moi je vous amener le
communiqué ils ont dit il n'y a pas de
risque voire voyez l'exposition au
bisphénol a ne présente pas de risque
pour la santé des consommateurs
comment une agence peut-elle dire sans
titre parce que c'est un communiqué de
l'agencé
alors qu'elle a interdit le visionnage
sur les biberons tessin alors vous voyez
bien que ça ça veut dire que l
elle n'accepte même plus le principe de
précaution est elle en quelque sorte
elle dit l' inverse de ce qu elle a dit
en 2011 puisque ils ont accepté à ce
qu'on enlève le missionnaire au niveau
des biberons donc c'est si vous voulez
dire que remettre addiction parce que
même en fait sur les effets on ne peut
pas se sent obligé de se demander si on
estime que le bisphénol a est dangereux
sur le nourrisson
pourquoi il serait pas dangereux aussi
sur l'adulte et donc sur les autres
parce que je rappelle que le bisphénol a
est présent dans les plastiques
transparents mais aussi sur les résines
à l'intérieur des objets métalliques
comme des canettes et de conseillers
voix
conserves et la nacelle j'entends
beaucoup de choses donc c'est vrai que
pourquoi l'interdire d'un côté sur
certains types d'emballages de produits
non mais la question est légitime terre
que pourquoi la même vulnérabilité entre
un enfant une femme enceinte et puis la
population générale donc non mais la
femme enceinte en l'occurrence est
touché cessons ces son enfant à naître
ce prix touche et ça le problème c'est
que le bisphénol a il n'y en a plus dans
les biberons il n'y en a plus dans les
contenants alimentaires en france mais
il y en a dans les verres de mes
lunettes
il y en a donc dans les dvd dans le
terrain dans le téléviseur dans lequel
vous nous regardez du bissonnet y en a
partout
donc ça veut dire que les femmes
enceintes qui porte un foetus elles sont
toujours exposés au bisphénol à part
d'autre part d'autres sources
d'exposition et la naissance a fait un
énorme travail là dessus pour essayer
d'identifier les sources d'exposition à
cette substance
donc c'est pas parce qu'on a interdit un
series la pointe de l'iceberg même de la
loi d'avoir un vibrant dans la bouche le
bébé a déjà déjà exposé c'est ça
justement la problématique des
perturbateurs endocriniens c'est une
question d'éthique parce que là on est
on est vraiment au coeur de la de la
discussion et sur la complexité de d2
l'action des modes d'action des
perturbateurs anouk rien et qui doivent
nous conduire assez radicalement à
repenser la façon dont on fait de la à
la fois de l'évaluation des risques mais
aussi dont on réglemente les substances
effectivement j'ai eu la question des
biberons temps largement discutée
il faut rappeler qu'aujourd'hui comment
on est exposé à au bisphénol-a à 80%
notre exposition elle résulte de notre
exposition alimentaire de ce qu'on mange
parce qu'effectivement il ya du
bisphénol a dans les résines dans les
contenants dans les canettes dans les
boîtes de conserves etc etc
et donc c'est essentiellement à travers
ce qu'on mange qu'on exposés au
bisphénol a mais on peut en retrouver
effectivement dans l'environnement ou
dans des usages assez particulier les
papiers thermosensibles et tickets de
caisse dans certains types de papier qui
peuvent conduire une exposition notable
et on se rend compte que effectivement
ce que nous on a mis en évidence à
lagence sur lesquels il ya discussion
aujourd'hui c'est que la femme enceinte
quand elle va s'alimenter pendant sa
période de grossesse et bien elle peut
être exposée au bisphénol-a à travers
son exposition alimentaire et dès lors
qu'il ya exposition à des fenêtres
extrêmement sensible du développement du
foetus et
il pourra y avoir des effets sur les
générations futures et en particulier ce
qu'on a mis en évidence ces des effets
sur la glande mammaire mais il ya
d'autres effets sur le cerveau et le
comportement et c'est ce que je veux
dire est qu est ce qu on en sait plus
aujourd'hui sur les effets donc
effectivement on parle du cerveau le
métabolisme en général la fertilité
voilà donc nous estime ça c'est de façon
plus générale sur les perturbateurs
endocriniens qui vont être impliqués
dans des très très grand nombreuses
familles de déchets dont qu'on a qu'on
avait déjà évoqué est typiquement donc
sur le bisphénol a les effets les plus
critiques avaient été mis en évidence
qu'on a considéré comme étant des
dangers associés au bisphénol-a c'était
le développement de la glande mammaire
le cerveau le comportement reproduction
fertilité m et kellie vous vous dites
cette interdiction du bisphénol sap a
été une bonne décision parce que pour
les entreprises
le remplacer c'est c'est trop lourd à
supporter alors ce qu'il faut dire c'est
qu'effectivement la france est isolée
aujourd'hui dans la décision qu'elle a
pris ce que c'est le seul pays à l'avoir
aussi largement interdite l'europe
là on peut désavouer finalement en
faisant un pas en arrière et donc pour
les entreprises françaises ça peut être
effectivement une perte de compétitivité
par rapport aux autres entreprises
d'europe qui elles ne sont pas soumises
aux mêmes exigences et c'est ça que vous
vouliez souligner le côté effectivement
la question du biberon dont on a déjà
dit qu'elle visait à protéger des
populations vulnérables ans fouleront
parle en effet des contenants
alimentaires le fait d'interdire
sur un seul état membre une substance
posent d'énormes difficultés à
l'industrie d'une part parce que le
calendrier n'est pas forcément réaliste
pour mettre au point techniquement
parlant des solutions de substitution
est par ailleurs du point de vue de
l'évaluation de leur sécurité sanitaire
je ne sais pas dire aujourd'hui si
l'ensemble des études ont été conduites
elles permettent d'affirmer qu'à long
terme on aura pas on n'aura pas
d'impacts sanitaires ou environnementaux
donc il ya quand même un problème de
calendrier par rapport à cela
est-ce qu'on pouvait pas anticiper
sachant que ça fait quand même quelques
années que le problème se sont pointés
du doigt et le bisphénol en l'occurrence
et voyez aujourd'hui nous n'avons pas de
consensus dans l'évaluation scientifique
à plusieurs organismes internationaux
européens agence européenne qui n'ont
pas le même avis la même appréciation de
l'évaluation du risque par rapport à la
langue c'est ce pourquoi parce que l'on
ne prend pas en compte les mêmes études
on les apprécie pas de la même façon les
ponts des repas la même façon et en
effet vous l'avez évoqué on évoque
d'autres thèses mécanistiques n'est ce
pas donc une différente divergences
d'appréciation l'industrie observe ses
divergences et le constat c'est que ça
mène à des réglementations qui divergent
au niveau des états membres et qui
complexifie énormément le travail de
l'industrie
oui moi je voudrais racheter quelque
chose quand même au niveau des
entreprises parce que vous n'en this i
pé pa quand même parce que ça fait plus
de 25 ans qu'on sait que cette molécule
dès les problématiques mais il y en a
plein d'autres vous étiez avec moi sur
la stratégie nationale sur les
perturbateurs endocriniens qu'a mis en
place le gouvernement
il ya plein de pays comme la suède comme
le danemark comme la finlande qui si
maintenant les salades qui sont aussi
des perturbateurs endocriniens etc et on
sait qu'un jour ou l'autre il va falloir
les enlever si vous voulez au niveau de
l'industrie moi ce que je reproche c'est
que pour nous le principe de précaution
c'est un principe d'innovation il
faudrait et on vous l'a proposé de faire
un partenariat public privé pour dire il
faut trouver des molécules de
substitution
parce que l'europe elle va être en
avance à métro si elle protège ses
citoyens européens et vous comme moi on
a des enfants on a nos enfants qui vont
avoir des enfants
on se dit si l'idée que les citoyens
européens se sentiront protéger parce
qu'ils ont une industrie proactive et
que ça va empêcher d'autres pays en
dehors de l'europe de venir avec des
produits on
vu sur les métaux lourds qui sont
bloqués à la frontière parce qu'ils ne
respectent pas la réglementation on est
gagnant
et nous on va gagner d'un point de vue
industrie et vous êtes toujours un peu
en retard d'un métro au centre c'est que
ça peut justement créer de l'innovation
économique innovation de l'angoissé des
briolance de la santé pour que vous
voyez là mais je sais que ça colle la
chimie est au coeur de ces l'industrie
de la substitution la chimie depuis son
origine
elle ne cherche qu'à remplacer les
substances pour les rassurer pour
améliorer leurs fonctionnalités
techniques
ce n'est que cela la substitution
réglementaire elle amène une charge
supplémentaire pour les entreprises qui
n'est pas nécessairement pertinente
or justement innover il faut faire
attention à cela elle mobilise l équipe
de chercheurs pour une substitution qui
n'est pas toujours à valeur ajoutée mais
on s'y sur le marché vous mettez des
molécules qui sont pas des perturbateurs
endocriniens
avec aussi il faut on peut pas le maître
du jour au lendemain il faut qu'on fasse
des études écotoxicologiques il faut
qu'on voit si elles peuvent pas être
plus dangereuse mais en avait on en veut
dire est qu'il faut protéger et nageurs
comme et puis il faut il faut aller de
l'avant
j'entends bien mais aujourd'hui ça va
cherche souvent elles sont un peu retard
dominé gouverner prise par une
réglementation pour que vous aimez les
retards on va continuer à en parler
on est en train de comprendre les enjeux
sont considérables et l'industrie se bat
pour gagner ce combat on va ré écouter
un extrait de votre documentaire
stéphane freiss et michael semé les
responsables politiques doivent être
conscients de l'objectif est de
l'origine de la manufacture de doutes
exprimés mais des mémos explicite de
l'industrie du tabac dans les années 50
10 ans si nous sommes le doute dans
l'esprit du public et des décideurs nous
pourrons protéger notre produit la
cigarette pendant deux ou trois
décennies des gaules est donc une
stratégie très explicite reprise par
d'autres secteurs quand ils estiment la
traduire menacer la santé fait de débat
contradictoire
c'est ce qui fait sa force d'ailleurs
c'est que c'est un processus de doute
permanent qu'on a besoin de ce doute
permanent et c'est d'ailleurs très sain
d'un fabian intellectuelle de remettre
en question ce qu'on pense de façon
permanente et c'est là où c'est très
pervers c'est que en déformant
artificiellement en fait c'est en
amplifiant
doute là l'industrie parvient en fait à
utiliser la science contre un homme
patrick levy vous avez dit en préparant
les missions c'est compliqué en tant
qu'industriel dette dans l'incertitude
mais bon vous je vais rien vous
apprendre vous êtes scientifique
l'incertitude c'est un des moteurs de la
science le principe c'est de dire non
une idée pour la dépasser ont démontré
une autre et quand on regarde le
documentaire on se dit que les
industriels ont bien compris ce principe
là et que quelque part en fait ils
utilisent un peu la science contre elle
même ce qu'on al'habitude effectivement
gérer l'incertitude
on a beaucoup plus de difficultés à
l'algérie dans le temps et là elle a
géré dans un contexte réglementaire
vous évoquiez démarche proactive
l'identification des perturbateurs
endocriniens aujourd'hui on n'a pas de
définition au niveau européen et on n'a
pas de stratégie de ces mature
aujourd'hui nous avons un cadre
conceptuel élaboré par l' ocde qui est
totalement lacunaire pour lesquels les
tests ne sont pas encore disponibles
vous le savez et on sait qu'il faudra au
moins cinq à dix ans pour arriver une
stratégie d'évaluation complète des
perturbateurs endocriniens qui se passe
par une accréditation au niveau de l'os
et des oeufs il ya en contient problème
de validité des essais dominique gauvin
ses essais en fait on a besoin que ça
retarde toujours toi mais je pense que
là aussi on est un peu au coeur de
l'enjeu c'est à dire que la difficulté
pour les grandes agences sécurité
sanitaire aujourd'hui c'est pas de
discuter des dangers des risques on
connaît tous aujourd'hui c'est le front
c'est les risques d'un certain et on
travaille on ne travaille de façon de
façon intéressante que sur la question
des risques incertain effectivement sur
les perturbateurs endocriniens
aujourd'hui ce qu'on essaie de faire
avant d'arriver à ces fameux critères
dont on a vu qu'ils relaient finalement
d'une élaboration qui se fait aussi dans
un contexte politique c'est finalement
d'essayer de de réduire le plus possible
les incertitudes mais des incertitudes
il y en a évidemment parce qu'on est
dans un contexte qui n'est pas
normalisée on commence à comprendre les
mécanismes des faits donc au bout d'un
moment quand est-ce qu'on bascule entre
eux je ne suis pas sûr à 100% mais j'ai
suffisamment d'éléments de preuve pour
que finalement je me dise le doute
profite il à la femme enceinte au
bisphénol est derrière le bisphénol jeu
le substitut par quoi
je ne rejoins pas monsieur lévy c'est
qu'effectivement on est dans un contexte
qui est loin d'être complètement
construits par contre je suis sûr que
lui et moi on peut assez facilement se
mettre d'accord sur dix noms de
molécules pour lesquels on peut penser
de façon très raisonnable qu à terme et
modulo le fait donc on dispose de tests
avaient ré on converge aura pour dire
c'est des molécules dont il voudrait
mieux assez rapidement envisager la
substitution dans le documentaire moment
on entend à ce qu'en fait on comprend à
ce que serait que le problème est très
vaste et très complexe
l'enjeu ici est très différent du tabac
ou de l'alcool qui sont des problèmes
très ciblée puisque les substances sont
partout à un moment on n'entend en gros
ce qu'il ya sur la table ses quarante
années de réglementations industrielles
qui pour voir c'est vrai ça ou pas on
est dans une construction de la
réglementation qui est progressive au
gré de l'acquisition des connaissances
scientifiques il ya eu un changement
fondamental avec l'arrivée de reach qui
a renversé la charge de la preuve les
industriels depuis 2008 sont devenus
responsables
la génèse est donné ce qu'on voit dans
le documentaire vous pouvez réexpliqué
choristes un règlement européen qui
impose aux fabricants et importateurs
d'acquérir des connaissances sur les
substances et d'évaluer leurs risques
sanitaires et environnementaux
sur l'ensemble du cycle de vie des
substances de la fabrication jusqu'à la
fin de vie n'est ce pas donc c'est un
changement extrêmement important c'est
un règlement qui se met en place
progressivement
on a déjà traité les très fort tonnage
et vous d'ailleurs l'étude d'impact qui
a été commandé et essence évaluer sa sas
a un coût énorme pour vous ça coûte très
important mais c'est un mécanisme que
nous acceptons nous sommes moteur
d'ailleurs par rapport à ça on achèvera
la mise en place de ce règlement qu'en
si vous voulez c'est très important la
réglementation reach et c'est une
particularité de l'europe que n'a pas du
tout les états unis s'ils voulaient
grosso modo on avait cent mille
molécules voyez dans tous les éléments à
qui nous entourent qui nous habite
d'ailleurs
et là dessus on en connaissait très peu
pour ya eu la réglementation reach
on avait tous lobby chimiques qui
étaient contre cette réglementation
reach a été un combat au niveau du
parlement européen vous pouvez pas vous
imaginer
on l'a obtenu cette réglementation et
depuis c'est vrai qu'industrie accepté
bien sûr d'enregistrer de faire toutes
les études etc et on se retrouve
maintenant avec des produits chimiques
qu'on connaît de mieux en mieux parce
qu'il n'a toute une série qu'on
connaissait pas et les nouveaux passe
automatiquement par cette réglementation
ici sont toxiques cancérigènes mutagènes
reprotoxiques ils sont éliminés
et ça c'est une valeur ajoutée qu à
l'euro alors maintenant dans la
réglementation reach il n'ya pas les
perturbateurs endocriniens et donc nous
on veut les faire rentrer mais à partir
du moment où il ya les critères et ses
critères pour tout vous dire on les a à
l'heure actuelle mais ils sont bloqués
parce que l'industrie a voulu qu'ils
aient une étude d'un bois l'économie et
alors justice arrive justement parce que
le temps passe donc cette étude d'impact
est arrivé alors qu'on attendait une
réglementation la suède comme vous
l'avez expliqué tout à l'heure ça ne lui
a pas plu du tout novembre 2014 a décidé
d'attaquer la commission devant la cour
de justice de l'ue eux pour ne pas avoir
respecter ce délai
la majeure partie des 28 états membres
représentés au conseil européen lui a
manifesté son soutien le parlement
groupe et est le et le parlement la
commission des affaires juridiques
qu'est ce qui peut se passer demain si
bas les 28 et amendis banon n'est pas
d'accord avec la commission
ils vont ils peuvent réglementer chacun
au plan national comme la france l'a
fait écouter ou l'as pas ça parce que ça
s'éduque et s'apprend le québec mais
d'après la santé publique
et là une question politique lac la cour
de justice européenne va rendre son avis
bon alors j'espère qu'elle va le rendre
très vite mais nous on n'arrête pas en
tant que parlementaire on a encore saisi
la commission
quand j'ai fait passer le film avec les
gens de la commission santé je suis allé
voir le commissaire de la santé à
l'heure actuelle qui est un lituanien et
qui veut faire avancer ce dossier
certes il faut qu'on pousse la
commission pour montrer à monsieur
juncker qui est très business ins et
c'est le business is business donc on a
la santé pour eux c'est quelque chose
qui les ennuis parce que ça va à
l'encontre si vous voulez de du
développement à court terme c'est à dire
un des premiers signes envoyés par un
jean claude juncker le nouveau président
de la commission arrivant en fonction
c'est il a que le par un tour de
passe-passe de tableau en échange les
portefeuilles d'une direction générale à
l'autre les fonctionnaires de la
direction générale environnement qu'on
voit dans le film dont je pense les
téléspectateurs peuvent deviner qu'ils
ont résisté à l influence des lobbys ont
été dessaisi du dossier au profit de la
dg sanco la d16 des recettes même des
jets qui essayait de les empêcher de
travailler
de quoi on parle on parle de certains
effets pervers de de l'ultra libéralisme
c'est l'ultra libéralisme et puis après
il faut bien que vous rendez compte
qu'il ya le traité tasta le traité entre
l'union européenne et les etats unis
j'explique parce que là où ça se
complique encore c'est que effectivement
en ce moment les enjeux sont pas que
européen et qu'en ce moment la
commission est en train de négocier avec
le tti paix le partenaire partenariat de
libre échange transatlantique et la
qualification des perturbateurs
endocriniens rentrent en ligne de compte
donc je résume en gros si le partenariat
rentrer en vigueur des entreprises
américaines l'exercice est vrai pourront
faire condamner des états européens par
détiennent des tribunaux arbitraux si
jamais la législation du pays est trop
restrictive en matière environnementale
et leur faire perdre de l'argent par
voie de conséquence donc il ya quand
même il ya quand même de quoi être
pessimiste et surtout le grand public et
pas très informé de ces choses-là renard
le tti pc très mal connue connaissent
alors il ya taffetas où tu étais ipc le
même show est alors de plus en plus
pendant la campagne européenne a
beaucoup parlé de taffetas là où les
gens sont très furieux et même
maintenant les politiques commença à se
rendre compte si cette espèce de
tribunal
si vous voulez qui est au dessus des
états c'est à dire même si la france dit
on refuse le bisphénol a dans tous les
contenants alimentaires elle va les
etats-unis qui ont dit qu'ils vont
vendre des conserves bondir à bord vous
attaque puisque vous nous pénaliser
l'investissement mais ça va au delà de
ça parce que dans ce traité sous laisser
des tarifs non douaniers c'est à dire
que les américains ne veulent pas qu'ils
aient une réglementation européenne
parce qu'il va falloir qu'ils s'alignent
sur la réglementation européenne
c'est pour ça que la commission a joué
un double jeu elle ne veut pas à ses
critères pour qu' il ya des échanges
mutuels entre les états unis et l'europe
et qu' il n'y ait pas cette notion
perturbateurs endocriniens
c'est pour ça que c'est un enjeu capital
et en plus il ya une urgence par rapport
à l'épidémie de maladies chroniques ont
à l'heure actuelle sur l'étang salé pas
normal et patrick et dans une bagarre
ils doivent tous les documents internes
que j'ai pu obtenir de la commission ses
échanges avec les lobbys c'est très
clair que l'industrie a utilisé ces
négociations pour le taffetas att ip
comme un levier en disant si vous passez
une réglementation sur les perturbateurs
endocriniens
ça va nous poser des problèmes au niveau
du commerce international et donc la
commission européenne l'europe sera
vulnérable d'un point de vue juridique
ce qui en général
un discours auquel la commission est
extrêmement sensible et pour juste pour
préciser cette menace que représentent
ces ce arbitrage en dehors des systèmes
juridiques que michèle rivasi est évoqué
c'est un système qui existe déjà et par
exemple le l'australie qui a mis en
place un système de plaques et de
cigarettes neutres comme ce que la
france s'apprête à faire a été attaqué
par philip morris sous prétexte que ça
entache ses bénéfices et ça veut dire
que en gros un état démocratique ne peut
plus décider prendre une décision qui a
pour but de défendre la santé publique
parce que ça attaque les profits d'une
multinationale
patrick lee et puis hong kong
globalement évidemment l'industrie
chimique est favorable à une forme
d'harmonisation entre les états unis et
l'europe
en revanche en ce qui concerne le risque
chimique et l'évaluation de risques
chimiques la sécurité des produits
compte tenu d approche extrêmement
différente entre les états unis et
l'europe
ça va bien au delà la réglementation on
peut pas imaginer aujourd'hui un
processus de reconnaissance mutuelle
parce que c'est un peu ça dont il est
dont il est question
on le droit est complètement différent
aux etats unis c'est plutôt basé sur le
consensus sur l' approche volontaire
alors quand l'europe en europe on
légifère donc on pas imaginer une
reconnaissance mutuelle aujourd'hui donc
ça va être long compliqué un mot pour
finir il reste 30 secondes de ligue en
mer est-ce qu'il ya quelque chose au
moins qu'on peut dire aux consommateurs
en attendant est ce qu'il ya des choses
qu'on peut faire à titre individuel
non c'est extrêmement compliqué
aujourd'hui sur les perturbateurs
endocriniens parce que effectivement y'a
rien absolument rien qui vous dit quand
vous consommez un produit qu'il peut y
avoir à l'intérieur des perturbateurs
endocriniens et c'est tout l'enjeu des
critères effectivement tout le contexte
réglementaire est prêt dans un grand
nombre de réglementations qui concerne
le consommateur ans allie tous les jours
il manque les critères ces critères sont
stratégiques et urgent alors il faut
rester un parent un dernier mot parce
que normalement moi je dis à tous les
gens qui nous écoutent regarder dans la
liste des produits de tous les produits
il faut pas qu'ils aient d'escale at il
faut pas qu'ils aient de bisphénol il
faut pas qu'ils aient des bromure et
cetera il faut éliminer le plus possible
des perturbateurs dans votre envers là
on peut inciter les consommateurs à
aller se renseigner sur les différentes
substances merci à tous d'être venus sur
ce plateau la semaine prochaine laurent
bazin débattra avec ses invités sur les
prisons je vous retrouve dans trois
semaines pour un documentaire sur
l'utilisation de la torture par les
etats-unis après le 11-septembre a très
vite sur public sénat
enfin